all right you are - didn't - rocking
with the rook as always these videos are
brought to you by advanced diagnostics
USA
we are in a 2019 RAM 2500 and for
starters to plug into this vehicle you
must use the star connector driver side
plugged in there right into the stock
connector bank so we are going to in
this instance I'm gonna be raising yes I
passed the pin code and that was super
fast zero keys programmed and then we're
gonna go to program proxy keys bypass
pin code warning please follow the
instructions carefully complete this
procedure within 60 seconds so the 2500
is different than the 1500 were you up
on the 1500 you actually press the key
to the push-to-start button on the 2500
you do it similar to how the older
proximity systems work you just hold it
near center console and press and
release the unlock button twice there's
one key programmed seed you're complete
let's try it
you know bada-bing bada-boom 2019 Ram
2500 proximity key programming with the
advanced diagnostics smart probe